hello everybody we left off we needed to
see or get the line to see red the Eagle
is to see blue all right moving on I've
just decided I'm gonna completely
abandon the whole sang them every part
because I lose track and then I look
like an idiot
and it just interrupts the flow if
you're watching this altogether so I'm
just gonna say hello and then goodbye
and then I'm gonna scream a lot in
between it okay what do you got anything
Oh more switches eight up eight down I
remember I remember
yep yeah I don't know I don't know
probably not eight up it ain't down
anymore
Briggs would adore a lantern this looks
creepy but I'm so brave done there to me
who's in here oh who wants some nothing
oh hey hey fu man can't see me I'm
behind a barrel
I'll get out of here ah get out of here
get out of here Connie get out of here
guy
get out of here guy no no just because
I'm a ha I'm by light you can't see me
if I don't look at you you can't see me
that's how it works yeah yeah get out of
here yeah your buddy Oh get out of here
ah I know no no no I got dammit god
dammit get did nut huh huh nope Oh get
out of here get out of here ah get out
of here come on
why does nothing follow my instructions
oh hey hey oh nope nope nope nope nope
nope
I appreciated this lesson level oh maybe
he's gonna leave hello
yeah nope huh
oh he knew it was good for him moving on
there was nothing in that room anyway
that's locked what is this alright oil
oil
ah come on Oh nope nope nope nope
I refuse no no no no aah
get out here no no that's right
[ __ ] right off Oh buddy you know welcome
here hey ho hey ho hey get out here oh
come on how they see me so easily
cuz I'm standing in the right under a
lantern get out of here get out of here
where'd you go get that oh hello
nobody come on I'm trying to progress
here these monsters is just being
tedious not scary just annoying
yeah how was in that door keep trying
buddy
um yeah he's gotta go off and disappear
and in the meantime I'm gonna go in the
room that you came out of ha you so
stupid ha look at you in your stupid
face
oh yeah what a loser
what do we got here hey why am I so
insane upkeep hello
give me East Winkie ok that's that
nothing useful there
he's still there man these monsters do
not want to disappear hi
ah what the hell mama slip pass you on
ninja ghost recon the Tom Clancy
Splinter Cell style I'm the best
No 4:15 okay four of 15 down even I can
solve that puzzle I'm terrible at
puzzles I need to use my tinder boxes
again once again it's like an amnesia
I've never used my tinderboxes all right
okay for up 15 down was that it is that
it I don't know or a 59 yep yep yep yep
it always up there monster are you still
here
nope four up 15 down okay ah come on
give me another there we go okay like
this and that's no better at all but
whatever Oh for up 15 down let's see um
come on come on I'll move you son of a
get down there for up 1 2 oh you son of
a [ __ ] oh come on I'm seriously I'm
guys I'm moving my mouse like a million
miles an hour all right so listen up
this down
oh you I will kill you and your family
it's just cuz they propped it up just a
little too high and it suddenly stops
working okay
[Music]
la la okay there we go
Oh genius genius super genius
um my prize should not be a monster get
out of here get out of here nope no I
refuse hello
bang bang II smash
get out of here don't even think about
it do not even think about it no no no
no fu man if you go away go away
no one likes you No uh yeah no don't
come over here don't come over here dawn
oh I've got a fist ready for your face
buddy
oh don't make me don't make me do not do
not come back yeah yeah there you go
that's more like it Oh ugly naked body
just get it out of here no one likes you
you're ugly you're never gonna have a
girlfriend
you're never gonna get laid you're not
gonna have any friends no no no okay was
he still there am I looking at him
behind the fog ah no screw that
okay all right finally yeah out of here
man
seriously these these guys aren't scary
they're annoying Oh blue blue get it
blue glass shard huh just glass what's
the point of that
not even an orb but whatever I'm not
picking all right I made it cool make it
progress now do I need to get to blue
glass shards cuz there are two eagles
maybe maybe
poink now yeah ah damn it I gotta get
another one let's see hello there it's
another door here where do you lead
little friend to the dining hall fu fu
man is this still my house because I
must be loaded loaded it up ah darn it
darn it ooh hello what's going making my
way across the way I'm such a wordsmith
alright open up door open up door going
down the corridor
don't be luck don't be ha the archives
all right bring it on hey this looks
familiar
near where my bedroom is are there gonna
be more monsters that stay long past
their welcome
probably oil boy eat away all right ah
can't hide from me tinderbox open it's
stuck
well then I will fix that bunk nope you
gotta hear who's in here
who wants some nobody that's what I
thought
hello anybody know a lot of empty rooms
man this is like a cycle
and these there's not much light what
does oh no no no no no uh fu fu fu fu @
foo foo foo foo o ass right off up right
off buddy f off you can't touch this
y'all I'm in my corner can't find me in
my corner yes right that's right
he's still there you there buddy no you
know I didn't think so
did he go already oh thank you then yeah
I'm tired of these monsters just [ __ ]
around hello hello okay please go all
right here wasting oil man it's just
really ridiculously dark in this room
like unnaturally dark oh this looks
ominous I like this hello
I wouldn't even notice that um what does
ah no no no gimme gimme gimme
ah No who was that who was that I'll
fight you it was nobody
this is a random noise like I was scared
back off man
all right nothing in there yeah okay I'm
gonna take the time here to pause the
video thank you guys so much for
watching and I will see you in the next
part bye-bye